the Carter five is finally here and
Selena Gomez and cardi B are bringing
the sleigh on a new track plus we got
the perfect fall cocktail for your
weekend all right guys this is the daily
Denny I'm Denny direct Oh duh and it's
also the end of the week so you know
what that means it is new music Friday
and the rap gods have finally blessed us
with little Wayne's long-awaited album
the carter five and it's soul it you
know it's been seven years since we got
new music from Weezy and let me tell you
it was worth the wait
[Music]
that fire right there is Monalisa its
Wayne's track with Kendrick Lamar and
that is the only part I can play for you
guys but it's the one I keep going back
to
now the Carter five is already climbing
the Billboard charts but will it stay
there
Kanye is dropping his album yandi on
Saturday but even he doesn't think he
stands a chance to out chart Wayne
Tweedy we know it will come in number
two - my brother little Wayne and that's
lovely University gay and Wayne music at
the same time now considering recent rap
beefs Nicki Minaj in cardi B I love the
love Kanye + all T no shape but I'm like
Nicki Minaj who was a little butthurt
about her number two album Kanye doesn't
have anything to prove guys he just got
a lot to say alright but Selena Gomez
cardi B DJ sneak and ozuna also released
a banger today called cocky cocky take a
listen
[Applause]
[Music]
besito get Suavecito baby
ducky ducky ok get us Selena with the
espanol I add this one to the playlist
this weekend alright guys
but keep it with the international Flair
going oh my god the lights are coming
down on me alright my favorite artist
the NOx teamed up with Sophie Tucker to
give a taste of Brazil
this is Brazilian song
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right that's an amazing song but
i'ma go seek shelter and do some mezcal
tasting coming with me are you guys it
is still Hispanic Heritage Month thing
you know what it's also five o'clock
summer which is why I got my man rather
reap goal here we're gonna do a mescal
cocktail but with the fall twist right
absolutely this is also a new season a
new season right so what are we making
today so today I'm gonna make it a
variation or Negroni a Negroni to read a
classic Italian cocktail but we're gonna
be making it with Miss cat in Silencio
making a clarified version of it it's an
all white brownie as you guys know miss
cow is on age and unrest it so I love
miss yeah it's incredible
all right so we're gonna start with the
most basic which is taking your basis
spirit everything is equal parts so is 1
ounce miss cow one ounce of aperitif and
one ounce of dry vermouth so I'm gonna
make one and then you're gonna have an
off track I don't know I'm pretty clumsy
I'm done right before that we also took
a shot before so I might be able to do
it with Miss Cal you could do anything
right so you're gonna take the small
part of your [ __ ] okay fill it up to
the top and that's one ounce all right I
told you so now I can say we're gonna do
in a 1 ounce an aperitif it's a bitter
liqueur has a lot of that full kind of
richness to it a little herbs a lot of
yeah perfect okay I'm nailing it so far
go come on damn we're gonna do dry
vermouth right he's gonna have the
sweetness that you want in your cocktail
and again 1 ounce 1 part 1 part 1 part
yeah 3 equal parts
there you go and spill all right so now
we're gonna get the eyes
introducing Ice Cube we probably want to
erase that okay great see that's some
sexy ice that's when you know it's gonna
be a good card right this is a mystery
cocktail which is one of the oldest ways
I'm making cocktails so you need a
steering glass and you need a spoon
and then you're gonna stir one of the
cool things about muscala silencio is
that you can take any cocktail and just
replace whatever base bread with Miss
Scott with that and he's gonna be
incredible I'm into it so now we're just
four okay into the glass it smells
really good yeah oh yeah
full smells like fall come on now smells
like my Hispanic roots so now I'm gonna
do a nectarine which is a fruit in
season mm-hmm we're gonna be a little
garnish with it what could you do any
grow an issue thing yeah you can do a
grapefruit twigs you can do an apple
Twitter's okay anything so shall we we
shall alright step fall to heritage and
to Miska Cheers oh that is good well
cheers to you look thanks again thank
you I'm gonna finish this for sure all
right
[Music]
honestly that was so good but I'm a
lightweight
alright guys before we go I do have some
bittersweet news to share after today
the daily Deni is going on a little
hiatus no I'm not running off to eat
slay love I'll actually still be here
doing my thing on ET and ET online
popping up in different videos and of
course still interviewing your favorites
but trust me there are some really
exciting things in the works but that's
all I can say for now so be sure to
follow me at d director on instagram and
twitter and thank you guys so so so much
for watching the daily Deni I hope you
were informed and also had a little fun
too and big thanks to my crew we're
small and mighty but made this thing
frickin fly so I'll see you around
here's to the end of one ERA in the
beginning of another I know they're
gonna be that little okay alright guys I
bet you're gonna miss seeing this mug